what if you delivered a Tesla Model y to
1908 when you arrive you'll notice the
streets are still dominated by hor drawn
carriage but the first Ford Model T is
just starting to roll off the assembly
line it's built entirely by hand and
just 11 units are produced per month
find Henry Ford and show him the future
of cars by giving him a ride in your
Tesla he'll be shocked by the 3.5 second
0 to 60 acceleration and the over 300 M
Driving range Mr Ford will immediately
begin investigating the possibility of
electric vehicles and have his own
prototype built by 1920 General Motors
will quickly follow suit with electric
vehicles becoming mainstream by the
1940s the world will move entirely away
from fossil fuels by the 1970s Elon Musk
will instead make a name for himself as
a space tourism Pioneer and he'll be
running a fully functional operation
when you return to the present day